rather than feeling shoehorned into an
already complete experience ghosts of
tsushima's iki island expansion feels
remarkably integral to sucker punch's
open world action game it might be a
newly added episode but it feels like it
could have been there all along iki
island's inclusion brings new depth to
protagonist jin sakai while providing
even more of what made the vanilla game
fun and compelling
[Music]
if ghost of tsushima was about jin
failing to live up to the expectations
of his father figure lord shimmura his
adventure to iki island is about jin's
biological father kasumasa sakai failing
to live up to his son's expectations the
vanilla game dedicated a lot of time in
jin's character arc to his feelings and
regrets about his father's death and
with iki island sucker punch finds ways
to explore that event and their
relationship in a lot more depth whether
you're playing the expansion after
having finished ghost of tsushima when
it launched on ps4 or you're venturing
to the island midway through a full
playthrough of the game it's notable how
much the iki island diversion feels like
an important part of jyn's journey the
story is a strength of the expansion
especially if you're already a fan of
ghost but it's not the only one much of
what's on offer here is more of the same
that means more fast-paced combat with
multiple enemies that require dodging
parrying and adjusting your fighting
stance mid-battle more environmental
puzzles in which you need to scale
castles or shimmy along cliffs to reach
distant shrines and more quiet moments
gazing over landscapes or collecting
random objects iki island doesn't break
the mold so much as increase its size
although the expansion also makes a few
fun additions to the overall game that
bring a little more variety you can
venture to iki island once you're
working through ghosts second act after
discovering a coastal village where a
new mongol leader has poisoned several
of the inhabitants the psychedelic drug
doesn't kill its victims though it
drives them to madness locking them in
painful visions of their greatest fears
and their regrets from the past this
follows you
this enemy leader a woman called the
eagle has garrisoned her forces on the
nearby iki island so jyn sets out to
stop her from gaining a foothold and
launching a new campaign against sushima
jin's arrival on iki provides a big
contrast to the rest of the game this is
a location where the locals aren't
trusting of or deferential to their
samurai lords in fact the islanders hate
samurai and the sakai clan in particular
so there's a ton of emotional baggage
for jin to work through and interesting
character interactions for him to have
as he works to help the islanders while
concealing his true hated identity
though the tale goes in some predictable
directions it works because so much
focus is placed on jin's feelings and
flaws as he works through them forced to
reconcile with a past he's been avoiding
even throughout much of the original
story jyn's internal conflict is
exacerbated by his interactions with the
eagle herself early in the iki story jin
is captured and poisoned by the mongols
and you'll spend the rest of the
expansion's main campaign grappling with
visions from jinn's past what kind of
stuff watches his father die these can
be triggered by anything from sneaking
up on enemies to running out of stamina
while sprinting to seeing the corpse of
an animal killed on a hunt the visions
create a fascinating intermix between
the goals of the mongols and jyn's
personal insecurities and past and give
the game a good excuse to constantly
throw in flashbacks and context that
broadens his personal story the eagle
makes for a good villain too although
the main campaign for iki island is
pretty short and you'll wrap it up in
just a handful of hours especially if
you mainline it unlike koten khan the
eagle is constantly portraying her
military campaign on iki as benevolent
and making offers to jyn to bring him
into her fold and open his mind to new
possibilities the lore items scattered
throughout the island and the side
quests you can complete add to the
picture of an almost religious fervor
surrounding the eagle which makes your
journey across iki feel a little
different than just fighting another
bunch of mongols the enemies are however
mostly just another bunch of mongols
so don't expect major alterations to
combat the expansion does add a few new
tricks to your arsenal though the main
one is the horse charge which allows you
to hit a button while mounted and barrel
through enemies who are on foot
it's a fun move that lets you open up a
fight by damaging all the enemies in a
pack and once you upgrade it and find
the optional horse armor attached to one
of ike's major side quests it becomes a
pretty useful addition to jin's many
combat options other combat alterations
are smaller in scope another set of
armor from a side quest takes away your
ability to parry unless you land a
perfectly timed parry but rewards you
with deadlier counter-attacks wearing it
tweaks your fights just enough to make
them challenging in an all new way while
making you feel extremely powerful
you can also find some new charms that
encourage different play styles like one
that lets you fire three arrows instead
of one finally one town has a sparring
mini-game where you need to adjust your
fighting style in a way that goes beyond
the usual change in stance to deal with
your opponent's unique approaches all of
these little tweaks offer up some
options for changing how you fight and
add a little extra challenge to the game
without pushing you far off the path
ghost of tsushima has already beaten
apart from expanding on jin as a
character iki island hits high notes
with its environment design and the
puzzles hidden therein iki is another
gorgeous landscape on par with sushima
itself and constantly looks amazing as
you explore it also has a few long
satisfying environmental puzzles to work
your way through standing with the best
of what showed up in the base game one
highlight has you searching for lost
treasure by making your way across a
fleet of shipwrecks and the further out
you get the more volatile the ocean
becomes as waves crash against the
wreckage you can't just fling yourself
through space the way you do in every
other example of these puzzles you have
to time your jumps and pay attention to
your surroundings lest a wave crest a
rock at the wrong time and sweep you
back into the water
there are a handful of tsushima's open
world activities to complete like haikus
and bamboo strikes and a few that are
unique to ikky such as archery
challenges but the best new additions
are animal sanctuaries these locations
are exactly what they sound like and
each has jin playing a short tune on his
flute that provides a bit of a rhythm
minigame for you to interact with and
rewards you with a new charm for combat
you tilt your controller up and down to
match the tone of the flute and as you
play animals creep closer to interact
with you none of the flute songs are
particularly challenging but each of the
sanctuaries is a nice contemplative
moment where jin pets a cat or a monkey
giving you a few seconds to take in the
landscape and just relax
all of what iki island brings to ghosts
of tsushima is good if you already like
ghost tsushima however the base game's
issues remain so if sucker punches take
on the open world didn't thrill you
before don't expect to change your mind
now you'll still wrestle with the camera
during combat especially as the mongols
come flooding at you from all sides and
while iki island is a fun place to
explore it's littered with a lot of the
same by the numbers open world
activities and collectibles that the
vanilla game was where iki island excels
though is in adding some new dimensions
to the rest of ghosts of tsushima its
exploration of jinn's backstory and his
character bring more depth to the base
game's tale that improve it overall and
its beautiful new landscape provides
both more of what works about the
vanilla ghost and a few good if slight
tweaks on the formula nothing is a
drastic departure but it's a lot more of
the good stuff refreshing sucker punch's
already solid open world game and
providing some interesting reasons to
revisit it
[Music]
[Music]
anyone else